morning the drew brees needs to quickly
issue a clarification apology and or
comment on the situation yesterday and
he has within the past several minutes
on instagram and on twitter this from
drew brees i would like to apologize to
my friends teammates the city of new
orleans the black community nfl
community and anyone i hurt with my
comments yesterday in speaking with some
of you it breaks my heart to know the
pain i have caused in an attempt to talk
about respect unity and solidarity
centered around the american flag and
the national anthem i made comments that
were insensitive and completely missed
the mark on the issues we are facing
right now as a country they lacked
awareness and any type of compassion or
empathy instead
those words have become divisive and
hurtful and misled people into believing
that somehow i am an enemy this could
not be further from the truth and is not
an accurate reflection of my heart or my
character this is where i stand
i stand with the black community in the
fight against systemic racial injustice
and police brutality and support the
creation of real policy change that will
make a difference i condemn the years of
oppression that have taken place
throughout our black communities and
still exists today
i acknowledge that we as americans
including myself have not done enough to
fight for the equality or to truly
understand the struggles and plight of
the black community i recognize that i
am part of the solution and can be a
leader for the black community in this
movement
i will never know what it's like to be a
black man or raise black children in
america but i will work every day to put
myself in those shoes and fight for what
is right
i have always been an ally never an
enemy i am sick about the way my
comments were perceived yesterday but i
take full responsibility and
accountability i recognize that i should
do less talking and more listening and
when the black community is talking
about their pain we all need to listen
for that i am very sorry and i ask for
your forgiveness that is the entirety of
the drew brees comment and apology chris
your thoughts
well i mean it's it's really well
written and it addresses a a lot of
different topics there and i i think
it's you know first off the right move
by drew brees to admit you know wrong
and to show people that yes he's he's
willing to fight in or take that next
step in a positive direction to help the
black community i do think this will go
a long way to help soothing over
teammates and other offended
african-american people in the country
and i think it'll take a little bit more
to he's probably going to need to go on
tv and address this head-on a little bit
that way too i think that will go a long
way
but either way this is a good start and
you know to drew brees again
this is a guy who's done a lot of good
in his life i certainly don't want that
to be taken away here you know i think
he got himself in trouble by kind of
trying to play both sides there's no
doubt about that uh but do i think he
cares about the african-american
community i do i do i don't think this
is a guy that's fooled the nfl and
teammates for this long in the locker
room by being some closet racist and
hasn't you know and
and now is being caught no i don't i
just think you know there's some issues
there that he wasn't well thought out on
and really
trying to see where it offended why it
offended what the real issues were and
he got caught trying to play both sides
and it came back to bite him in the butt
but
i thought this was a really good
statement and i i expect to see him more
throughout the day really
here's what i'm curious about and i want
to be fair to drew here he did what he
needed to do at least for now and i
agree with you at some point we need to
see and hear him the way we saw and
heard him yesterday there needs to be
symmetry and the way the apology is
delivered to match the way that the
statements were delivered in this day
and age
it is not
unusual and it's not inappropriate
to be skeptical when something like this
comes out it's just not right did he
write this was it crafted by a pr firm
how many drafts were there who did the
first draft did he merely sign off on it
did he do the first draft when you speak
it
when you deliver the apology in the same
kind of format that you delivered the
words that caused the need for an
apology it becomes easier to assess is
this real or is this just okay hey i
have to sign off on this in order to put
the fire out that is a real reaction in
a sophisticated civilized society that
sees this stuff all the time and and
justifiably ask questions and here's the
thing
i look at this
comment from the apology i made comments
that were insensitive and completely
missed the mark on the issues we are
facing right now as a country
okay
have you changed your position on
whether or not it's appropriate to kneel
during the national anthem have you
changed your position on whether or not
you believe it's disrespectful to the
flag to neil
is it just the way it came out
do you still believe
what you believe or have you decided
based upon
further reflection that it's not
inappropriate
to take a knee during the national
anthem it's not disrespectful to the
flag to the military to the country and
and i i think chris and again there's no
middle ground here if everything that he
has said in this statement is true
i don't think he can balance that by
saying i also believe everyone should
stand for the national anthem
because
this moment is fueled by that
recognition
that what colin kaepernick was trying to
tell us four years ago has very real
merit and the time for listening to his
message and acting on it is four years
late for people like
george floyd and others who have been
killed in the four years since then at
the hands of law enforcement so that's
what i would have a question about it
and and i i i
and and i don't want to say it's not
enough
but again
there needs to be that symmetry well
it's not enough not mike it's not i want
to know i i want to know
has he changed his stance on the things
he said yesterday that caused this
problem that's the question i have after
i see that it is a very well written and
very appropriate apology but but this
wasn't a slip of the tongue
this wasn't something that he casually
said when he was talking to a reporter
off the record and didn't know it was
off the records or anything like that
this is something that reflects his
beliefs and his values reiterated from
four years ago
has that changed
in the past 18 hours or does he still
believe that that he will never agree
with disrespect to the flag the military
of the nation
yeah well that's why it's a good start
but you know to your point and to what i
was saying here at the start of the
segment right is it it's got to be more
you got to be able to put the face
and see the emotions of the person and
have some hard questions asked of drew
brees and have him handle those you're
right without a prepared statement or
maybe somebody there helping them along
with the subject in general uh that's
when it's really going to hit home when
people can put the face to these words
and go okay drew brees has apologized i
can see in his face he's legitimately
upset about what he did and there is
compassion and caring for the
african-american community i think
that's going to soothe a lot of people
so he means to me like if i'm i'm drew
brees and listen i i don't want drew
brees to be ruined forever because of
this all right i don't uh like i said i
know there's a lot of good he's done for
the world and the community but if i'm
him like i'm going on msnbc today i'm
going on cnn i'm going on fox news and
i'm going to hit these subjects hard and
and try to start to write the situation
because listen he he doesn't he can be
fine with saying hey listen i don't want
to
kneel during the national anthem and do
that that's not how i would like to
protest i'm going to try to find other
ways but i completely support my
african-american teammates and all those
who do want to protest that way and what
that causes for and what they're
fighting for so not that he has to kneel
but he's got to certainly let everybody
know that hey
kneeling for the national anthem is
certainly less egregious than kneeling
on somebody's neck
for nine minutes and murdering them and
to me that's what's gotten lost in
translation with these comments and
that's why i think he needs to go on tv
and kind of
have everybody hear these hear these
words come out of his vow
and and chris with all due respect to
our friends at the various cable news
networks and obviously we're on a cable
sports channel this is bigger than
cable this is a today show moment right
you're right mike yeah you're right
this is and this is and and see everyone
scrutinizes the these things who do you
pick to be the one who interviews you
for this is it someone who's going to
throw you softballs is it someone that's
going to ask you tough questions and how
do you hold up under questioning with
someone who is going to come at you and
challenge you and test you and there are
things in this statement that would for
a skilled interviewer who is committed
to asking aggressive questions provide
fodder for pointed questions i already
pointed out the one issue what what what
are you saying are you saying that you
have changed your position on whether or
not you agree with what you perceive as
disrespect you even regard it now as
disrespect do you understand it's not
disrespect do you understand that people
would seize on that word to justify
ignoring the message of colin kaepernick
and the one thing that and and look i i
i want to be fair here but we got to be
fair the whole story
any time i see i am sick about the way
my comments were perceived yesterday
there's a subtle amount yes that
bothered me that was the number one
thing right blame shifting to the
audience you were wrong in how you
perceived my comments now he adds to
that i take full responsibility and
accountability well if you do
then don't say
i'm sick at how my comments were
perceived yesterday there was no
misperception of his comments he said
what he said this wasn't vic fangio
trying to make a very narrow point and
being too broad in the language which
language that he used in making a very
narrow point he said what he said
and that's what i'm gonna have a hard
time juxtaposing
what does he believe now
about
kneeling during the national anthem does
he believe it is disrespectful to the
flag
uh or has that changed
and uh that's what i think the next step
is here so maybe tomorrow morning on the
today show or one of the other morning
news
programs
we'll have drew brees in person
for
a conversation and that conversation
will be scrutinized very carefully by
his teammates by everyone folks in new
orleans uh and and he's going to have to
you know words on a page mean nothing
when the ultimate reality is to sell in
your voice with your demeanor with your
facial expressions with everything right
that what you said
previously
you don't believe anymore chris
yeah well first off i'm glad you brought
up that was probably the number one
sentence i looked at
that bothered me that my comments were
perceived i mean i echoed the same
sentiments you do you know no no we
didn't perceive them anyway we
got them right and we don't like what
you said and it was wrong and what you
said all together so i think that's the
issue there but
again i do think going if he wants to
you know repair the damage that's done
in the locker room and continue to be
looked at as a leader in our sport and
in our country and if he does ask have
aspirations to you know be in politics
one day or anything like that then i
think yes you got to go out and show
everybody your face take this head on
continue to talk about it
you know admit where you were wrong
admit where you have growing to do as a
human being and need to be better uh i
think that ultimately is going to have
the biggest effect when people like you
said and i said already is can put that
face and see the emotions and the look
on the guy's face to see if it's real
and has it hit home
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports